40 years I've been chasing Sydney they
finally give it to me what they do they
give it to him the same night I'll
always be chasing you Sydney I'll always
be following in your footsteps
I bless you
when I was in college first starting out
as an actor they asked each one of us
what we wanted to do I said I want to be
the best actor in the world
life has taught me to just try and be
the best that I can be
and I thank the academy for saying to me
that on this given night I was the best
that I could be
Antoine Fuqua
a brilliant young filmmaker
African-American filmmaker I don't know
where you are Antoine love you
Ethan Hawke my partner in crime
beautiful wife I love you so much you
put up with me in spite of myself my
beautiful children at home I told you if
I lost tonight I would come home and
we'd celebrate and if I won tonight I
would come home and we'd celebrate well
I'm coming home we're celebrating God
bless you all